capucine s'est acheté un faux cul 1
[Musique]
alors moi j'aimerais que vous vous
avouer quelque chose aujourd'hui à là
pour réveiller quelque chose sur vous
fassiez votre coming out sur quelque
chose
un truc que vous nous avez jamais dit je
collectionne les crânes humains ah ah ah
oui j'en ai cinq six j'ai couché avec
trente filles n'ont même temps oui fait
36 grandes filles j'étais content et
parce que nous mais avec des moustaches
mais non quand j'étais au canada ouais
j'étais ajouté j'étais jeune garçon
j'étais pas trop moche ouais tous mes
potes étaient évidemment très attirée
par les filles
ouais et dobbins le sait le on sortait
vendredi et samedi et je les suivais
donc on est dans les mêmes bars et comme
je draguais pas trop que j'étais pas
trop trop bas cheval ailé les filles me
trouvais mon lourd pepo thévenet et bien
18 ans forcément pour se taper une
chèvre ouais bah oui j'étais comme nomme
pardon c'est le groupe allait filer chez
mémé évidemment non évidemment à chaque
fois que j'allais en boîte de nuit
bachot père c'est une belle révélation
battu voilà bravo avait aussi
collectionne les cra du match côté foot
dans le cul moi je me suis fait passer
pour un autre
en fait dans les années 90 il ya un
joueur de foot auquel je ressens je sais
pas si vous avez la photo il s'appelle
jacques glassmann c'est celui qui a
révélé le scandale - real marseille mais
qui vous ressemble et on était à une
série prend la photo apparaît en était
inséré mairie des latrines
mais l'on sent il recevait un prix du
fair-play de la fifa et comme on se
ressemble beaucoup
tous les journalistes venaient vers moi
monsieur glassman bravo c'est formidable
et gagner un prix bien mais je ne suis
pas jacques glassmann et au bout d'un
moment j'avais trente journalistes
étrangers qui disait mais monsieur glace
maïs étaient autour de moi monsieur de
la semaine c'est une honte
pourquoi vous snobé la presse
internationale vous prenez pour qui vous
avez un melon pas possible donc au bout
d'un moment j'ai dit vous m'emmerdez
tous on imagine oui et j'ai fait
l'interview comme si j'étais jacques
glassmann capucine s'est acheté un faux
puis un olivier dont la l1 derrière
exactement il s'agit d'un faux derrière
je suis content la chirurgie esthétique
c'est vrai que je me suis acheté comme
méchante ailleurs un d un fessier
hambourg est le seul vrai moi j'ai le
gland albator c'est pardon
albator le corsaire le corsaire
quand j'ai quand j'étais petit je jouais
sur une chaise j'ai basculer la chaise
elle a basculé
donc le corps a basculé mais mozilla
s'était coincée non et donc ça a déchiré
ça fait cher oui ça déchirait l'algérie
déchirée le frein est donc résultat et
je n'essaierai je n'ai rien senti exact
fait circoncire mais sans rabat voilages
et sauf que je suis remonté dans la
maison et j'avais dû sont jusque-là ça
saigne beaucoup leur ait dit ça c'est
beau j'ai donc été aux urgences ils
n'ont pas pu me faire d'anésthésie et on
marque uzi le gland non à vif
ah ouais d'où mon nom et mon surnom
d'albator de terminator non on n'a pas
bien compris tu peux montrer non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]